há três anos eu fui convidada para falar
no festival de idéias e aí eu perguntei
qualquer o tema
e aí me responderam você pode falar
sobre o que você quiser eu falei bom
então eu vou falar sobre algo que tem
habitado há algum tempo e que eu chamei
de escrita feitosa
me colocaram para falar logo depois do
almoço eu falei não vai aparecer ninguém
e daí eu pedi para o meu marido e pra
pelo menos que ele tivesse ali que eu
não falasse com um monte de cadeira
vazia para minha surpresa não só a fala
lutou como meu marido precisou se
levantar e segurar as divisórias estavam
ameaçando cair e aí eu comecei até a
percepção de que aquilo não fazia
sentido só pra mim que fazer sentido
para o outro e eles devem estar se
perguntando mas que quer a escrita
feitosa a escrita feitosa não fala sobre
cartas de amor mas sobre o amor que
existe em cada palavra a escrita feitosa
ela é a percepção de que existe a alma
em tudo que você escreve você busca
dentro de você coloca no mundo e o mundo
te devolve nesse gesto grande é a
percepção de que na sua escrita a você
a forma como você está como você está no
mundo quem é você como você enxerga o
mundo e o que você traz dentro de você
a escrita é primordialmente um encontro
só que a gente se esquece disso
e isso nasceu muito da minha percepção
porque escrevia textos e as pessoas
mandavam mensagens parece que você está
conversando comigo e eu comecei a pensar
com a diferença entre um texto que
conversa com o outro
em outro texto que a pessoa esquece um
minuto depois eu percebi que isso tinha
a ver com entrega com quanto você se
colocava na sua escrita
só que a gente escreve um e-mail e acha
que aquilo é só técnica que aquilo é faz
um e mail frio esquece que tem você ali
pior de tudo você esquece que tem uma
outra pessoa do outro lado e aí a gente
não promove o encontro e por que que a
gente tem tanta dificuldade em escrever
com tanta alma porque dá medo porque
quando a gente coloca gente na escrita
a gente está num agente se mostra ea
gente não quer se mostrar
eu costumo dizer que a escrita é como
uma piscina em que você pode colocar só
o seu dedo ali pra sentir a temperatura
você pode até haver a de mergulhar você
pode até o trampolim mais alto pular eu
gosto muito desse tipo de escrita das
escritas que promovem um mergulho
profundo
eu costumo dizer que a escrita tem
cheiro tem som e aí as pessoas me
questionam
mas é possível fazer o texto de escrita
feitosa sobre economia política esportes
sobre chacina
eu falo claro quem está escrevendo um
robô ou é uma pessoa porque esse é uma
pessoa eu sinto muito mas tem você ale
só que a gente nunca se dá conta disso
eu lembro que tinha uma aluna que me
questionava muito sobre isso porque ela
falava que o editor dela queria ver
números taxa o texto
eu falei quem está se escondendo
você está se escondendo atrás dos
números
você não está se mostrando texto é vida
ea gente perde a chance de contar essa
história
quando a gente se esconde atrás da
palavra
a palavra tem força
eu gosto muito de escrever textos sobre
comida e a relação disso com a vida com
as minhas memórias em que o conto muito
sobre como a minha relação com a minha
mãe foi sendo moldado e construída
através da cozinha e do cheiro que vinha
da cozinha e hoje a gente está muito
acostumado só com livros que trazem
receitas ou que trazem modos de fazer de
novo o automatismo a gente não entra nas
camadas
a gente fica na superfície e aí quando
tem alguém que fala sobre saudade sobre
amor sobre história através de uma
panela de barro uma geléia de jabuticaba
o outro se reconhece a lei e eu com os
textos mais viscerais foram aqueles em
que eu sentir que eu mais encontrei o
outro porque eu entrei dentro dele e ele
se enxergou ali e aquilo voltou pra mim
eu lembro de uma pessoa que me escreveu
pra pra falar que foi inspirada nas
linhas narrativas que ela teve a idéia
de pedir pra mãe ensinar a cozinhar
a mãe estava passando por um processo de
depressão profunda e aí a mãe foi até a
cozinha pegou os cadernos de receita e
as duas cozinharam juntas e ela me disse
depois de muito tempo
foi a primeira vez que eu voltei a ver a
minha mãe sorrir
se isso não é poderoso eu não sei o que
é
a palavra de uma força impressionante e
o mais triste e que a gente está
desperdiçando a palavra todo dia
todo dia a gente desperdiça no nosso
automatismo eu vejo muito vocês devem
experimentar isso na time line do
facebook de vocês palavras de força
palavras de história fortes como
empoderamento disruptivo economia
criativa sustentabilidade das palavras
elas são fortes mas agentes vazia quando
a gente deixa de contar as histórias
a gente tem que contar as histórias das
mulheres que estão em estado de risco a
gente tem que contar as histórias as
histórias estão pedindo para ser
contadas
a escrita é um reflexo da vida que você
leva todo dia só que você acha que ela
só mora no extraordinário si só vai
poder escrever um texto incrível quando
você fizer o caminho de santiago de
compostela quando você tirar o seu
sabático ou quando você fizer uma viagem
incrível pra ásia eu vou te falar que o
extraordinário talo ordinário não vida
que você leva todo dia porque quando
você desliga o despertador uma história
acabou de acontecer
a maneira como você coloca os livros na
sua mesa de cabeceira contam histórias
sobre você
histórias sobre saudade sobre escolha
sobre amores e porque é que a gente não
tá contando essas histórias de novo
porque a gente tem medo de se mostrar
porque a gente fica se camuflando e sabe
o que a gente está fazendo a gente está
desperdiçando vida a palavra tem que ser
intensa porque a vida tem que ser
intensa
a mídia adora falar de envelhecimento
gosta de falar dos cabelos brancos da
liberdade de ter de usar roupa que você
quiser
hoje dia 12 de agosto meu pai está
completando 81 anos está sendo muito
difícil pra ele envelhecer e pra mim vem
eliécer e eu sinto que o que ele quer
saber é como ele faz para se despedir da
vida sem cantador a percepção de que a
vida é finita traz isso pra gente e sabe
que é sabe que mais a gente não tá
contando essa história porque toda vez
que a gente mergulha numa história conta
como ela pede para ser contada
isso dói porque isso a gente tem que
tirar de dente tem que encarar as nossas
próprias dores e os nossos medos
é por isso que a gente não é intenso com
a escrita
só que pra mim a escrita é sempre o
encontro e uma relação com o outro
sou eu em você você em mim é a percepção
que existe em você e se isso não é uma
relação de amor eu não sei mais o que é
de novo escrita é uma relação de amor
profundo e de humanidade na sua essência
a escrita feitosa é isso é o encontro
com o outro encontro através da palavra
escrita feitosa é semente
eu hoje eu sei que eu não posso mudar
políticas mas eu posso transformar a
vida das pessoas pela escrita
então o que a gente siga se encontrando
na palavra e que a gente siga espalhando
o amor por aí
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]